Still ahead on this Monday,
Democrats are ramping up
their calls
to impeach President Trump.
Let's go.
They're trying to impeach me.
REPORTER: Democratic congressman
Brad Sherman
has filed an article
of impeachment.
Sherman, nobody impeaches me.
I think we're gonna be hearing
the word "impeachment"
a lot more often.
Wow. Unbelievable.
Sherman?
You know Congressman Sherman?
He's a white guy.
He's kind of a loser. Jew-y.
Help me.
I don't want to get impeached.
Sheila?
Is Sheila Jackson-Lee here?
People want to impeach me.
You realize that? Why?
Yeah. But besides that.
Where's Sherman?
Sherman?
Sherman!
Where the hell is that guy?
Oh, there he is!
Sherman? Where's Sherman?
-Mr. President...
-Yeah, I don't care.
Hello. Sherman,
you're gonna impeach me?
Let me tell you something,
I'm gonna impeach you.
I'm gonna make you feel
like Jeff Sessions
fell into a puddle.
You understand me?
You think you're tough?
You're fired.
Mr. President, you can't fire
a member of Congress.
That's stupid.
Sit down. Let's talk.
Okay.
Mr. President...
Where'd you get that,
a yard sale?
No, that probably goes back
100 years
here in the House
of Representatives.
-We've had it for a long time.
-Total junk, okay?
Well, Mr. President, first,
I'd like to serve
these papers on you.
-Wow. Thank you. -Usually,
you don't do that in person.
-Whoa. -It's been referred
to the judiciary committee.
And if the whole House votes
in favor of those articles,
you will be tried in the Senate
for high crimes
and misdemeanors.
TRUMP: I can fire Meatloaf,
but I can't fire this guy?
Got to find another way out
of this.
How's this?
I'll make a deal with you.
I'm one of the great dealmakers.
So, what do you want?
All I want
is this letter of resignation.
How's this?
What if I give you a cool name,
like the Bradster?
Or, like, Sher-man!
Like, "Hey, Sher-man,"
instead of "Sherman."
Or how 'bout, like,
Brad-ley Whit-ford?
If we could terminate
your presidency,
then I might be known
as the Sherman-ator.
"The Sherman-ator."
That's a weird nickname
to give yourself.
I might be known
as the Sherman-ator.
♪ ♪
Now, the crime in this case
is obstruction of justice.
-Fake news.
-It's illegal...
-No way. -...to use threats
or intimidation
with the intent to thwart a
federal criminal investigation.
Oh, big deal.
-Remember back in February?
-No.
You had dinner with James Comey.
Oh, God, that guy?
-You told him to go easy
on Flynn. -Let it go.
-Let it go.
-Go easy.
That's a violation of law,
that you tried to curtail
that investigation.
How does he know that?
Oh, right,
because I totally did it.
In May, you fired James Comey,
and then you said you did it to
thwart the Russia investigation.
Oh, yeah.
That's the thing I said on TV
in front of everybody!
Then you remember in July,
you were up there
with the New York Times?
-No!
-And you threatened Mueller
with being fired if he looked
at your personal finances.
That's three different threats.
That's obstruction of justice.
TRUMP:
This guy's relentless.
He's like a machine.
The Shermanator.
Mr. President,
look at the Watergate example.
-Uh-huh. -About a year
after the cyber burg...
uh, the burglary
at Watergate was discovered...
Whoa. Wait a minute.
There was a cyber burglary?
No, the cyber burglary
happened in 2016.
TRUMP:
Wait. Cyber... burglary? Duh!
The cyber burglary...
Shermanator. Shermanator.
Shermanator.
TRUMP:
It all makes sense now.
Are you like a time cop?
Are you traveling through time,
impeaching different presidents?
It probably goes back
100 years here
in the House of Representatives.
Brad Sherman, time impeacher.
A man who runs for office
in different times
working towards taking out
presidents to affect history.
That's fairly silly.
-I'm still working it out.
-Mr. President,
before you came here,
I was worried about our country.
Now I'm... very, very worried.
TRUMP: There is no fate
but what we make for ourselves,
which means
I had no choice but to send
a super-rich robot version
of myself back to 2017.
It's my only chance of escaping
my impeachment by...
The Shermanator.
♪ Dum, dum, dum ♪
♪ Duh-duh, dum, dum. ♪